power rankings time they're published at
pft every tuesday in the noon hour or
thereabouts i reserve the right to be
late but uh we have to be right on time
when the show's on the air to discuss
them and they are posted at pft chris
i'm going to rattle off the top 10 for
the benefit of the folks listening on
the radio the patriots shockingly are
still number one right the chiefs are
number two still cowboys bump from four
to three the rams are up from five to
four seahawks at five they were six
eagles dropped from three down to number
six packers bump up two to seven the
ravens are number eight the saints hang
in there at number nine after losing to
the rams and the vikings round out the
top ten after losing to green bay they
were number eight what do you think of
the top ten well i i mean i think you
got the right teams in there i'm not
going to argue that all right so i guess
what i want to ask you was there any
thought of the cowboys being two and the
chiefs being three did you entertain
that at all
no no because i mean you've got to have
a really bad showing
as a winner yeah to fall right and and
they they won 28 to 10 yeah even though
the offense only showed up for one
quarter it showed up pretty big in that
one quarter yeah it definitely did i
just wanted to know kind of your logic
because the cowboys i mean have looked
phenomenal and i know it's the giants
and the redskins and we're not ready to
crown them champs of the world yet but i
just wanted to know your thoughts there
okay here's the other one i got for you
though well let me hear your thought
process there with eagles
in front of the packers and ravens who
were 2-0 eagles kind of coming off that
underwhelming loss there on sunday night
yeah i mean look they could have won
that game even though more than half the
team as it seemed at the time ended up
being injured they were there they had
it and yeah they went on the road it was
a tough opponent it was a desperate
falcons team and and also i don't want
to be too dramatic in the movement in
the early week if the eagles aren't
really one of the top teams in the nfl
that will prove itself over time and
they will keep falling so you know the
ravens started lower because i really
wasn't sure what their offense was going
to be but as they are winning these
games and again look they they they
destroyed the dolphins who won't destroy
the dolphins this year and they only
beat the cardinals by six points at home
even though lamar jackson looks
phenomenal
it was not a blowout win and they they
should be more than six points better
than a team that at best is a work in
progress so you know the ravens still
bumped up three spots but but i i'm i'm
not i'm not going to give in to the
temptation after two weeks to have
all the two and oh teams clustered
together without interruption all the
one and one teams next and all the 0-2
teams at the bottom i i think there's
more nuance than that at play well what
gave you the what gave the edge to the
packers over the raid like i just look
at your top ten and i know you got
packer seven ravens eight i probably
would have gone ravens seven packers
eight i just you know because because
the packers you gotta look at where they
were last week yeah okay packers were
already ahead of the ravens right the
packers beat a team at home yeah that is
better than the team the ravens beat at
home so there's no reason to jump the
packers the the packers had ultimately
an impressive performance because they
scored 21 quick points and then they
held it together as long as they could
to keep the vikings from surpassing that
amount okay i you know look i just think
the vikings are better than the
cardinals so i'm more impressed by what
the back the packers have done
especially the packer i mean the packers
went to chicago and won yeah uh i don't
know the ravens could do that right now
we'll find out about the ravens this
week chris cause they go to play the
chiefs yeah so if the ravens are for
real then they win in kansas city
something they almost did last year yeah
well you know i just pushed you push
back there i don't know if we know what
the hell the bears are either too i mean
you know they had a shamrock up their
butt to win that game last week
so they could be an 0-2 football team
very easily that's where i want to get
to can we go to your 11 through 20
because i think this is the most
interesting part of your uh power
rankings this week
we can go to 11 through 20 let me give
the folks on the radio a very quick
rundown of 11 through 20. chargers 11
bears 12 up one spot even though they
stole that win in denver colt's 13
titans 14 brown's 15 builds 16 and then
the bottom uh or the continuation of the
the bottom of the top uh or the second
10 17 49ers 18 steelers 19 falcons and
20 texans all right have at it well i'm
i'm actually i think you're
disrespecting 16 and 17. i know that
they started down lower in your list but
i mean i certainly said year can make a
case and go the bills and the 49ers they
can be every bit in that conversation
you know ahead of the browns and hang on
hang on all right let's test this out
browns versus bills right now who wins
i'm not sure i i don't know i mean i
think that's a close one
it depends where that game's at i i
think
the way the building met life stadium
metlife stadium the bill's win that's a
tough one though so i don't if i think
if it's almost a tie i would give the
tie to the two-and-oh team i guess
that's where i'd go there that's that's
what i would say
40 yeah okay how about four well 49ers
browns are going to be playing on monday
night football in a couple of we're
going to see that in a couple weeks yes
you know so i look you know i i think um
again you're being nice to the titans i
guess is where i look at the bears colts
titans browns okay and uh i could look
at those and i i would i don't know
where i would have put that exactly i
think i would have had the bills and the
49ers ahead of them right now i do i
think they've earned enough in the first
two weeks with the way they've played
and then the bears colton's titans
browns have looked shaky enough uh
except for maybe the colts all right so
maybe i'll say the bears titans and
browns shaky enough to where i think i
would give the bills and the 49ers the
edge over the colton's titans and browns
colts titans and browns
it's
here's the problem and it's no different
than the weekly poll that they do in
college football that where you start
really does hamper your climb and you
need people in front of you to lose and
sometimes lose well whatever you gotta
talk to a committee i mean this is your
damn list you can move them there if you
want i mean what do you like i don't
want the movement
i don't want the movements to be too
dramatic and i do think that some of
these teams that are one and one are
better than the teams that are 2-0 i
mean the bills ultimately beat two bad
teams they beat the jets and the giants
and i you know i and and they started
lower okay can i still browse i would
take the rounds over the bills the
browsers
and beat the jets without sam darnold so
you're giving them a little more credit
than i think you know and you're not
giving the bills the same credit i think
you're being mean there
i think if the browns and the bills were
playing in cleveland the browns would be
favored by four and a half or five
points and if the browns and the bills
were playing in buffalo the browns would
maybe be a one point favorite or it
would be a push so i i'm comfortable
with the browns ahead of the bills okay
yep i don't think i could do that i
think i would have gone the 49ers over
those few but the rest of your list okay
i'm okay with that i mean i i got a
question for you oh i got a question for
you right what do you think about the
steelers without ben roethlisberger
still at number 18. uh uh oh i'm glad
you brought that up because i think
you're insane to put them there right
now i should have kept my mouth you
should have yes yes i don't i mean
they've looked not good at all i mean
they played competitive last week i
shouldn't say not good at all they
certainly had a chance to win that game
um but i would i would think i would
look at it right now and yeah i might
have had the steelers
not too much farther down in fact i
maybe just would have had the falcons
okay and the texans in front of them and
then probably the steelers and not
because i think necessarily the teams
are better but with the big ben aspect
of it as well i think i would have had
the steelers at 20 and then the falcons
at 19 or falcons at 18 texans at 19.
yeah you know and it's i i feel like
that now that the steelers are down and
out
this is the moment where the steelers
organization that i'm familiar with over
the years finds a way around to start
digging and and i vividly recall
1989 they lost to the browns 51 to
nothing in the first game of the season
they were blown out by the bengals the
second week of the season and they were
done they were cooked it was over
disbanded the franchise the vikings who
were a super bowl favorite in 1989 roll
into pittsburgh
for week three and the steelers won that
game and the next thing you know the
steelers made it to the playoffs in 1989
so so are you saying you were going to
pick a steelers upset maybe in san
francisco this week you think the 49ers
are buying their own hype a little too
much
i'm thinking about it oh
i'm definitely thinking about it we'll
find out tomorrow mikey likey he's
thinking about going with the upset
there okay
well i just think that when you and and
we know that this is real chris the the
concept of circling an opponent right
now the steelers are a team that other
teams are going to look at and say
yeah and uh i'm not sure how you would
transcribe that but they're just going
to have that attitude and it's going to
be a real challenge for your buddy kyle
shanahan to get his players to recognize
and appreciate that this is still a
dangerous football team and they can't
just go out there and coast because they
were able to kind of coast against the
bengals yes so it's going to be a
challenge home opener stay focused they
were away from home for a whole week
everybody's saying how great they are
they're back home kind of a little
celebratory you know oh we were gone and
now now our routine and and we're
playing a team that doesn't have a
starting quarterback all we're gonna be
three and oh we're gonna be 3-0 for the
first time since 1998.
well i don't i don't know you're right
and the steelers are gonna come in
pissed off as hell and ready to ready to
battle yeah i mean there's no doubt it
sets up as a trap game i'm just hoping
that yeah my buddy kyle shanahan and the
49ers that you know winning is still so
fresh and exciting to the team that they
don't fall into that trap i mean that's
what i'm hoping there and
i've liked what i've seen from the 49ers
through the first two weeks their
defense mike
their offense exploded last week but
their defense is going to be a force i
think when uh as the season goes on
and you know and again hit with the
steelers the the spirit is willing but
the flesh is weak do they have the
personnel necessary to do what they need
to do to beat the 49ers i've made my
final pick yet but i am at least toying
with the idea of the steelers pulling
off an upset of the san francisco 49ers
all right we need to take a break you
can see the full pft power rankings at
profootballtalk.com
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports